they are hidden in one of the most
secure art folds in the netherlands
thousands of artworks stolen from
victims of the holocaust are sold in an
effort to stay alive many of the owners
died in hitler's gas chambers those who
survived spent many years trying to get
them back these are the paintings
this is it
it took alfred fuzz and his family six
years to convince the dutch state these
two paintings were forcefully sold by
his grandfather in 1941 to save his
family you have to prove and to prove
again and again and again that you are
the heir
the hide behind all kinds of excuses
because
at the end of the day
i doubt that they want to give it back
with the knowledge of today it's it's
shameful
in 45 46 people were busy rebuilding it
wasn't a priority at all
but it took a long time to get it
to be a priority many stolen or disputed
pieces are still on display in museums
or public buildings like this painting
by dutch master masdar for decades shown
in parliament building until a few
months ago
a collection of paintings symbolizing
the impact of the holocaust more than 80
years later while some of these artworks
were handed over to the dutch government
immediately after world war ii they have
been in storage ever since and many
might never be returned to their
rightful owners
nazi leaders adolf hitler and hermann
goering had an obsession with art and
hundreds of thousands of stolen
paintings and artworks were collected to
build up their own museums in nazi
germany alfred fuzz is still looking for
more than 800 looted artworks that were
part of his great grandfather's
collection until 1933 when hitler took
power his grandparents were among nearly
100 000 jews transported to camp
westerborg in the east of the
netherlands
here is a place where is a connection to
the arts because
they were probably rescued because they
could find some money to pay off the
camp commandant the guy who was in
charge here
and he let them go but it was very very
rare that any jews were let out of here
and could go back to amsterdam
the camp was the last station before
auschwitz and other extermination camps
and is a symbol for alfred fuss fight to
get his family's art back we should
try to do our part in history
and to see what we can do in order to
get
back what was ours to get justice done
and also to show the world
that what however bad the situation is
and there's always
a
certain hope for redemption dutch
researchers have been given four years
to investigate the origin of thousands
of disputed paintings and returned them
to the rightful ears hoping to complete
what some say should have been done
decades ago
on al jazeera in the netherlands